[Musique]
ok je sais ce que je veux dire
pour moi la youtube c'était juste un
backup procédons dans l'ordre commencé
ma carrière à la télévision en france 5
avec 2 émission qui s'appelait le grand
et faisait le vin 20h alors le
live-tweet 20 20 c'est le fait de
commenter et de raconter en direct un
événement sur twitter ensuite j'ai été
chroniqueuse sur france inter pendant un
an et demi dans l'émission la tête au
carré donc le magazine scientifique moi
en tant que citoyenne j'étais frustré de
ne pas voir à la télévision le programme
que j'aurais adoré voir et donc je me
suis dis pas comme ça n'existe pas à la
télé je vais essayer de le faire moi
même
c'est comme ça qu'est né à la fois
l'histoire de l'univers qui était donc
un podcast vidéo
bonjour à tous je suis florence porcel
community manager officiel de l'univers
donc 30 semaines d'affilée j'ai fait le
jt du spatial et les sciences de
l'univers tout seul chez moi avec mon
dictaphone et ça a donné le modèle
standard de la physique des particules
alors moi je suis vulgarisatrice
scientifique
je ne suis pas youtube deux jeunes enfin
je fais des vidéos ça c'est vrai oui
effectivement
bienvenue mais mêler mes vidéos c'est
juste sur mon temps libre c'est c'est
juste un hobby
donc moi je suis comédienne de formation
je suis aux tris et donc je mets toutes
ses compétences au service de la
vulgarisation scientifique donc j'ai
écrit des livres je participe à des
projets de vidéos documentaires
télévisés j'ai fait la radio jeu
je fais des conférences je vais à la
rencontre des gens donc j'essaye de
vulgariser sur tous les supports qui
sont à ma portée et donc youtube en fait
partie mais voilà c'est pas mon métier
il faut le souligner c'est important
c'est la question à 100 balles alors les
rumeurs et les fakes news y en a pas
beaucoup dans mon domaine
ce qu'il ya beaucoup en revanche c'est
le complotisme et l'obscurantisme donc
de plus en plus les gens qui pensent que
la terre est plate
c'est pas bien ça c'est pas non c est
donc ça me permet important de bain de
de continuer à faire ce travail de
vulgarisation pour expliquer un peu la
méthode scientifique et et comment on a
réussi à savoir les choses je crois pas
qu'ils aient de mauvais vecteur pour la
vulgarisation je pense qu on en a
tellement besoin
oui faire des vidéos et vulgarisée par
exemple la première ynwa la première
image d'un trou noir par un trade sur
twitter ouais ouais c'est des super
outil mais voilà youtube ou dailymotion
ou n'importe quelle plateforme de vidéos
ou n'importe quel réseau social ce sont
des outils tout dépend de comment on les
utilise au laert les big secrets de
l'univers
il est préfacé par hubert reeves et il
traite de la cosmologie alors ça c'est
un mot un petit peu compliqué qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc qui en fait qui
veut seulement dire que on étudie
l'univers en tant qu objet physique
un exemple ça veut dire ben comment
comment il est né comment il a évolué
comme on y va continuer à évoluer ce
qu'il contient
ce qui l'est quelles sont ces lois les
lois physiques qui y prévalent j'essaye
d'expliquer ça encore une fois avec des
mots simples pour que un maximum de
personnes puissent comprendre ma
première vidéo elle date d'il ya dix ans
donc c'est dire si je suis vraiment un
dinosaure du web et donc ma communauté
elle a commencé à se créer à ce moment
là et effectivement à l'époque moi
j'étais étudiante en journalisme donc
rien à voir avec ce que je fais
aujourd'hui et donc j'ai vu évoluer en
fait elle elle m'a suivi dans mon
évolution de la fin de mes études à
on arrivait sur france info puis france
inter puis maintenant la vulgarisation
scientifique à temps plein elle est très
bienveillante
je me rends compte que maintenant dans
les commentaires
à chaque fois que les gens font des
commentaires sur mon physique ou son
agressif ou insultant ou menaçant ma
communauté prend le relais cet été en
disant ben voilà ce commentaire n'a pas
lieu d'être
retire ça s'il te plaît supprime moore
est ce que tu te rends compte que tu
peut blesser la personne en face et il
ya une sorte d'autorégulation qui se
fait comme ça et je voulais remercier
ces personnes qui font ça parce qu'en
fait c'est vraiment chouette c'est
vraiment le bon côté du web et des
commentaires et je remercie beaucoup
parce qu'on se sent soutenu en fait
derrière est une créature du web qui
m'inspire en voilà une question qu'elle
est bonne
aude gg
[Musique]
elle un programme qui s'appelle virago
qui est maintenant finie mais ça reste
en lits et c'est super ce sont des
portraits de femmes et c'est simone veil
alors ministre de la santé qui aura la
lourde charge de présenter le texte de
loi elle est formidable
bon là c'est bon c'est bon
[Musique]